[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصادي الليله معكم عبد القادر
العياط في الوقت الذي احدثه فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
البدايه من الخرطوم حيث عقدت عقدت الجلسه
النهائيه لورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
رغم غياب البرهان وكذلك حميتي
ثم الى نيويورك وتحديدا مبنى الامم
المتحده حيث اعتمدت الجمعيه العامه
بالاجماع قرارا وصف بتاريخه يطالب من
محكمه العدل الدوليه ابداء رايها بشان
واجبات الدول في مجال مكافحه الاحتباس
الحراري اما هذه الصور فتاتين من الكونجرس
الامريكي حيث ايدت اغلبيه اعضاء المجلس
الشيوخ تشريعا يقضي بالغاء تفويضات مضى
عليها عقدان من الزمن بالحروب السابقه في
العراق
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
من واشنطن الى تل ابيب توتر غير مسبوق
الكشف عن رساله غاضبه وشديده اللهجه من
بايدن يطالب فيها وبالتراجع عن التعديلات
القضائيه بعد تاكيده عدم نيته استقباله في
البيت الابيض
والتنياهو يتراجع عن حديثه بشان رفض
الضغوط على بلاده ويقول ان خلافات عرضيه
لا تؤثر على التحالف وفي وثيقه حصلت
الجزيره على مسودتها مشرعون الديمقراطيون
يطالبون بضمان عدم استخدام اسرائيل اسلحه
امريكيه في انتهاكات الحقوقيه
في استعراض متبادل للقوه روسيا تبدا
تدريبات بمنظومه صواريخ يارس النوويه
العابره للقارات وبمشاركه الالاف من
قواتها وتقول انها توقفت عن اشعار امريكا
بانشطتها النوويه واشنطن وسور تجريان
مناورات جويه وبرمائيه استعدادا لاي هجوم
قد يستهدف شبه الجزيره الكوريه
وسط تواصلي المعارك في الشرق الاوكراني
مؤسس فاجنر يقول ان القتال في باخموت اضر
قواته ودمر الجيش الاوكراني الكريم يتوقع
ان يطول امد ما وصفها بالحرب الهجينه بين
روسيا والدول الغربيه ومع بدء وصول دبابات
غربيه متقدما لاوكرانيا موسكو تدفع بمئات
الدبابات الى الجبهات
في غياب البرهان وحميتي خلافات تخيم على
الجلسه الختاميه لورشه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري في السودان ومصادر الجزيره تكشف
على اعتراض الجيش على عدم مناقشه الدعم
السريع في القوات المسلحه وحميتي يشترط
اصلاحا شاملا قبل المرور الى اصلاح الجيش
في لقائنا اليومي قبلاء الحصاد على
منصاتنا الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا معكم
استمرار توتر وتصاعد الازمه بين واشنطن
وتل ابيب على خلفيه التعديلات القضائيه في
اسرائيل الرئيس الامريكي اعلن انه لا ينوي
دعوه نتنياهو الى البيت الابيض بينما قال
رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان الخلافات
العربيه لا تؤثر على التحالف الاستراتيجي
بين البلدين واوعز لوزرائه بعدم التعقيب
على تصريحات الرئيسي الامريكي لاستطاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي الى اي درجه يؤثر
السجل بين ادارتي
بايدنغو على مستقبل العلاقات الاسرائيليه
الامريكيه وقد جاءت نتائج التصويت على
النحو التالي نحو
15% قالوا ان الاستجال بين الطرفين تاثيرا
كبيرا على العلاقات في حين راى 22% ان
تاثيره محدود
بينما صوت نحو 63% بالقول انه لا تاثير له
اطلاقا على العلاقات بين البلدين هذا
السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا على
المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا قبل ساعات من
توقف رئيسه تايوان في الاراضي الامريكيه
الصين تحذر من اجراءات مضاده اذا التقت
برئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي واشنطن تقول
ان سياستها تجاه تايوان لم تتغير وتطالب
بيجين لعدم المبالغه
[موسيقى]
افاد ديوان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان
رئيس الوزراء اوعز لاعضاء حكومته بعدم
التعقيب على تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي بشان
التعديلات القضائيه وبعد ان اعلن رفضه
للضغوط الامريكيه على حكومته قال نتنياهو
ان التحالف بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
لا يتزعزع رغم وجود خلافات عرضيه بينهما
كما تعلمون سبق للولايات المتحده واسرائيل
مرتا بخلافات عرضيه سابقه لكن يؤكد لكم ان
التحالف بين الديمقراطيه عظيمه وديمقراطيه
قويه وفخوره ومستقله مثل اسرائيل في قلب
الشرق الاوسط هو تحالف لا يمكن زعزعته
هذا وكان الرئيس الامريكي قد اعرب عن قلقه
ازاء ما وصلت اليه الامور في اسرائيل وقال
انها لا يمكن ان تواصل ان تواصل في هذا
المسار ودعا بايدن رئيس الحكومه بنيامين
ترياهو الى ايجاد تسويه حقيقيه والتخلي عن
مشروع تعديلات القضائيه وتوفير حل للوضع
الصعب الذي تعيشه الدوله افق تعبيره كما
اشار بايدن الى انه لا يعتزم دعوه نتنياهو
لزياره واشنطن في المدى القريب
لا اعرف ما اذا كانوا قد بلغوا نقطه تحول
لكنه وضع صعب ويجب عليهم حله ماذا تعمل ان
يفعل رئيس الوزراء بشان هذا القانون
بالذات
امل ان يتخلوا عنه
وبدوره قال وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
اتمار في حديث لاذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
على الرئيس بعيدا والاداره الامريكيه ان
يفهموا ان اسرائيل هي دوله مستقله وليست
نجمه اخرى في علم الولايات المتحده
هذا وقال موقع ولا الاسرائيلي ان مسؤولين
امريكيين حذروا رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ومقربين منه من استفزاز الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن وقالوا ان تحذيرهم لنتلياغو ينبع
تحديدا من ان بايدن يعرف نفسه كالصهيوني
ولديه خطوط حمراء حيث انه لا يحتمل المساس
بما يصفها بالديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه ونقل
موقع ولا عن مصادر رسميه اسرائيليه ان
بايدن بعث برساله شخصيه وسريه نقلها
السفير الامريكي في القدس
عبرت عن غضب البيت الابيض من اقاله
نتنياهو لوزير دفاعه
ولفت الموقع الى ان اقاله جالنت ادت الى
حاله من الغليان دفعت واشنطن لتوجيه رسائل
شديده اللهجه مفادها ان الاداره الامريكيه
تتوقع من نتنياهو وقف التشريعات القضائيه
بشكل فوري
واضافت مصادر للموقع ان مستشارين وضعوا
امام الرئيس الامريكي خيارات للضغط على
نتنياهو منها الغاء مشاركته في مؤتمر
الديمقراطيه لكن جميع الخيارات استبعدت او
استبعدت بعد خطاب نتنياهو الذي اعلن فيه
تجميده عمليه التعديل القضائي والبدء في
مفاوضات مع المعارضه
هذا وحصلت الجزيره على مسوده رساله يتم
تداولها بين مشرعين الديمقراطيين تطالب
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ووزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن بالنظر فورا فيما
اذا كانت اسرائيل تستخدم الاسلحه
الامريكيه بشكل ينتهك القوانين الامريكيه
الحاليه وتحث المسوده اداره بايدن على
اجراء تغيير في السياسه الامريكيه اعترافا
بالعنف المتصاعد وضم الاراضي وتجاهل حقوق
الفلسطينيين كما تدعو الرساله الى ضمان
الا تدعم اموال دافعي الضرائب الامريكيين
مشاريع في مستوطنات غير قانونيه وتطالب
مسوده الرساله الاداره الامريكيه بضمان
الا يستخدم جمع او جميع الدعم المستقبلي
لاسرائيل بما في ذلك السلاح والعتاد في
انتهاك حقوق الانسان وذلك من خلال تعزيز
المراقبه والمتابعه الماليه
صار تفاصيل عن هذه المسوده معنا من
الكونغرس مراسله الجزيره بسان ابو كويك
بيسان ماذا عن هذه المسوده التي تم
تسريبها للجزيره
نعم عبد القادر هذه المسوده التي حصلنا
على نسخه منها هي رساله طبعا موجهه للرئيس
بايدن ووزير الخارجيه
يتم تداولها حاليا بين مشرعين ديمقراطيين
في مجلس النواب والشيوخ يقودها السنه
للمستقبل في مجلس الشيوخ ونائب الديمقراطي
جمال بومن في مجلس النواب بغيه الحصول على
تاييد ودعم وتوقيع من اعضاء اخرين قبل
توجيهها رسميا للرئيس بايدن وتحث الاداره
الامريكيه وفق نصها على ان الان هناك نقطه
تحول ويجب على الاداره الامريكيه تغيير
سياستها اعترافا بالعنف الذي يزداد سوءا
عمليه ضم الاراضي
الاراضي الفلسطينيه وايضا الانتهاكات التي
يراها اولئك المشارعين طبعا بحق
الفلسطينيين يصفون الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الحاليه وفق نص الرساله بانها الاكثر
تطرفا من ناحيه اليمين يتحدثون عن مواقف
عناصر في هذه الحكومه
وما يدعو اليه اولئك ربما عنف وسياسات هي
معاديه للديمقراطيه ومعاديه للفلسطينيين
يقولون ان تاكيد الاداره الامريكيه بحسن
نيه وبشكل مكرر وتكرار اتخاذ اجراءات
متساويه لضمان الكرامه والحريه والامن
للفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين لم يكن لها اي
واقع لذا يطالبون الاداره الامريكيه
باتخاذ خطوات
والنص هذه الخطوات هي اولا النظر بعدم
وضمان بان الاسلحه التي
ودعم الامريكي لاسرائيل لا تستخدم تلك
الاسلحه
لانتهاك حقوق الفلسطينيين ايضا ضمان ان لا
تستخدم اموال دافعي الضرائب الام في
مشاريع في مستوطنات غير قانونيه وايضا
ضمان ان اي مساعدات مستقبليه لاسرائيل لا
تستخدم في انتهاكات لحقوق الفلسطينيين
ايضا يتحدث المشرعون عن ويربطون بين طبعا
التطورات الاخيره المتعلقه بالتعديلات
القضائيه وما تم الاتفاق عليهم من تجميد
مؤقت لذلك المسار بتلك التعديلات القضائيه
التي ستغير من شكل القضاء في اسرائيل يرون
ان هذه الاتفاقات ايضا لم تشمل اي بنود
ستقلل من العنف ضد الفلسطينيين على حد
قولهم او ضم اراضي ويعرضون عن قلقي من ان
ما يحدث فعليا هو عمليه ضم فعليه
لاراضي في الضفه الغربيه لاسرائيل لذا
ربما عبد القادر هذه الرساله قد تكون من
الاشد لهجه التي نراها حتى الان مو من
مشرعين في الحزب الديمقراطي تجاه اسرائيل
ومواجهه للرئيس بايدن بغيه الحصول
والمطالبه على خطه واضحه من قبل الاداره
الامريكيه للتعامل مع هذه المخاوف وفق ما
تم تداوله طبعا هناك عدد من المشرعين
المحسوبين على التيار التقدمي في الحزب
الديمقراطي في مجلس النواب كالهان عمر
ورشيده
قد وقعوا حتى الان على هذه الرساله ولكن
ما زال هناك محاولات لجلب المزيد من
الاسامي من مشرعين اخرين لدعمها وايضا
هناك معلومات تشير الى ان هناك منظمات
وقيادات يهوديه امريكيه ايضا تجمع الدعم
لهذه الرساله ومضمونها قبل توجيهها رسميا
للاداره الامريكيه رساله لك
طبعت العلاقه الامريكيه الاسرائيليه خصوصا
في المرحله الاخيره بعد تشكيل الحكومه
الجديده بتحالف نتنياهو مع احزاب من اقصى
اليمين هذا وقد وجدت هذه العلاقات نفسها
في حاله شبه صدام مع تصريحات ومواقف وصفت
بالمتطرفه وذلك لعدد من قاده الائتلاف
الحكومي خصوصا وزيري الامن القومي
والماليه ووضعت نتنياهو الذي يراس هذه
الحكومه في واجهتها
انتظر بنيامين نتنياهو سته ايام بعد فوزه
في انتخابات نوفمبر تشرين الثاني الماضي
لتصله مكالمه من الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
لتهنئته بفوزه لكنه تاخر محمل برسائل بعد
ايام من الانتخابات نقل موقع اكسيوس عن
مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم انه من غير المرجح
ان تتعامل اداره بايدن مع عضو الكنيستر
الاسرائيلي المتطرف
الذي كان مرشحا توليه منصبا وزاريا وما ان
تولى منصبه وزيرا للامن الداخلي حتى بدر
بني كثير لاقتحام باحات المسجد الاقصى
فكانت الاذانه الامريكيه هذه المره من
سفاره واشنطن في اسرائيل وصفه الخطوه بغير
المقبوله في الشهر الاول لحكومه نتنياهو
ثلاثه مسؤولين امريكيين اسرائيل وهم رئيس
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه ويليامبرز ورئيس
مجلس الامن القومي
ووزير الخارجيه انطوني بلينكن في عز
التصعيد الاسرائيلي في جنين يلتحق وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي
بشريكه بنكفير فيدعو لمحوي بلده حوار
الفلسطينيه تصفها واشنطن بدعوه للتحريض
على العنف وتحت نتنياهو على التنصر من
تصريحات شريكه في الائتلاف منتصف مارس
اذار افادت القناه الثانيه عشره في
التلفزه الاسرائيليه ان نتنياهو امر
وزرائه بالامتناع عن عقد لقاءات مع مسؤول
امريكيين الى ان يوجه له البيت الابيض
دعوه رسميه لزياره واشنطن والاجتماع
ببايدن يعود وزير الماليه للواجهه ينكر
وجود الفلسطينيين فتصف الخارجيه الامريكيه
تصريحاته بالمقلق للغايه وبالخطيره ويصل
الامر في خطوه نادره الى ان تستدعي واشنطن
سفر اسرائيل لديها بعد الغاء الكنيست
بنودا في قانون فك الارتباط بشان الانسحاب
من قطاع غزه واخلاء بعض المستوطنات في
الضفه الغربيه وتعتبره تحريضيا احدث
المواقف اعلان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
انه لن رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الى البيت
الابيض في المستقبل القريب بعد ان دعاه
للتخلي عن التعديلات القضائيه هذه
التوترات ليست وليده الحكومه الحاليه ففي
2012 رد البيت الابيض بالنفي على طلب
نتنياهو الالتقاء مع اوباما خلال وجوده في
نيويورك على خلفيه تصريحات بشان هجوم
محتمل قريب ضد المنشاه النوويه الايرانيه
وفي 2015 توترت العلاقات بين اوباما
ونيتينياهو بسبب اعتراض الحكومه
الاسرائيليه عدد الاتفاق بشان البرنامج
النووي الايراني كما الغيت زياره اخرى الى
واشنطن عام 2016 اي عمل انتخابات
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
اذا البيت الابيض يكرر دعوته القاده
الاسرائيليين
للتواصل الى ما وصفها بتسويه توافقيه تحظى
بدعم شعبي منسق والاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي
قال ان التسويعيه التي ستحافظ على الضوابط
والتوازنات وكذلك اتنهي الازمه في اسرائيل
نحث القاده الاسرائيليين على التوصل الى
تسويه في اقرب وقت ممكن وتعليقات الرئيس
بان علامه نياهو الابتعاد عن التعديلات
القضائيه يتوافق تماما مع ايجاد تسويه
تحافظ على الضوابط والتوازنات في اسرائيل
ينضم الينا من القدس امي خاي شاهين مراسل
الشؤون الدبلوماسيه في هيئه الاذاعه
العامه الاسرائيليه وكذلك ينضم الينا من
واشنطن السفير بيجي كراولي المتحدث السابق
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه اهلا بكم وابدا
بضيف اسئله من اسرائيل رساله غاضبه من
الرئيس الامريكي تقول لا نيه للرئيس
الامريكي باستقبال نتنياهو في البيت
الابيض وتطالبه بالتخلي عن هذه الاصلاحات
القضائيه كيف تصف العلاقه الان بين البيت
الابيض وبين نتنياهو
الابيض اليوم حاول ان يخفف من اللهجه من
قوه اللهجه بين الطرفين
كان هناك محاوله لتلطيف الاجواء ايضا
ومحاوله القول ان هذه الامور طبعا الامور
تعود لاسرائيل ومساله الاصلاحات
الاسرائيلي لكن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تريد ان ترى انتقال سلس نحو هذه
الاصلاحات
ومحاوله لتهدئه
الاجواء وتهدئه طبعا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ليست في وازع ان تملي اي شيء
على اسرائيل او تقولها ما ينبغي الى ان
تفعل ولكن
بينما هو معلن بشكل رسمي وبلغه دبلوماسيه
يبتعد قليلا عما يتم تقديمه لوسائل
الاعلام من رسائل شديده اللهجه موجهه من
البيت الابيض
لنتنياهو وبالتالي كيف نفهم ذلك
نعم هذا سؤال وجيها ينبغي يتوجه رومانيه
مسؤوليه البيت الابيض لكن بشكل عام البيت
الابيض
يريد ان يقول لاسرائيل نريد رؤيه هذا
القانون وهذه الاصلاحات تسحب من على
الطاوله لكن بالطريقه التي تراها اسرائيل
مناسبه اذن الامر يعود لاسرائيل وهذا ما
تحاول ان تقوله اسرائيل من خلال
من خلال سعيها لتلطيف الاجواء هذا اليوم
بالنسبه لما قله بايدن ولن يلتقين في هذه
المرحله بالامس
كان هناك
الشعور بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كانت تسعى لي الدخول على الخط وفتح صفحه
جديده ربما لكن سمعنا بان هذا الامر لن
يحدث لكن الامور لن تتعدى هذا الوضع ما
بين البلدين
ايضا لمحاوله فهم العلاقه الان الان الوضع
تجاوز تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي وما يدور
في البيت الابيض الى تحرك على مستوى
الكونجرس من قبل نواب الديمقراطيين وحتى
جمعيات يهوديه
لمسوده عن قرارات قد تتخذ بين قوسين ضد
حكومه نتنياهو ايضا كيف تفسر هذه العلاقه
الان بين البيت الابيض وبين حكومه نتنياهو
[موسيقى]
كان رئيس ياخذ
في هذا الاتجاه ما يحاول بيضا على قيامها
وادارته والشيئين محاوله
لتاكيد على العلاقات الطويله الامد
والعلاقات الاستراتيجيه ما بين اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وهناك طبعا عمق كبير لهذه العلاقه نحن
نعلم ان اسرائيل هي
ديمقراطيه في قلب الشرقه الاوسط
تستمر في النظر لهذه العلاقه باهميه كبيره
ولكن كيف
سيتم حل مساله الاصلاحات داخل اسرائيل
طبعا سيحدد تطور العلاق
بالتاكيد من وجهه نظر امريكيه هناك قلق
بخصوص هذه
الحكومه المشكله من ائتلاف فهذه الحكومه
ليست
بحكومه قويه
نتنياهو فاز بهذه الانتخابات بعد مجموعه
من
المحاولات الانتخابيه التي لم تكن تفضي
لحكومه هناك طبعا
متطرفين داخل هذه الحكومه وهؤلاء يشكلون
مصدر قلق بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حاول ان يطمئن واشنطن بان لديه
القدره السياسيه لاداره العمليه السياسيه
في البلد
هل يمكن القول لواشنطن لا تتدخلي في
شؤوننا الداخليه كما قال بعض اعضاء
الحكومه ما سرب من قبل موقع ولا يقول بان
الرئيس الامريكي غاضب جدا من اقاله وزير
الدفاع
نعم هذا صحيح هذا ما سمعناه نتنياه قام
بقاله
وزير
الدفاع وتم ايصال رساله قويه نحن نعلم ان
لديهم علاقه جيده معه وهم لم ترق لهم هذه
الحركه على الاطلاق
الاداره الامريكيه خلقه وغاضبه حتى من هذه
الخطوه وهناك قلق ايضا بخصوص الاستيطان
بخصوص الاصلاحات القضائيه
وغاضبون ايضا من التعليقات وردود افعال
الساسه لاسرائيل لكن السؤال ما هي الخطوه
التاليه كيف
ستتحول موجه الغضب هذه الى نوع من التهدئه
نعم ايضا قال بانه لن يستقبل نتنياهو روما
لن تكون هناك
مثلا اي اجراءات
الامريكيه واسرائيل لكن لا اعتقد اننا
سندخل الى المرحله التاليه التي ستكون
اكثر تصعيدا من القدس اينشتاين مراسل شؤون
الدبلوماسيه في هيئه الاذاعه العامه
الاسرائيليه وكذلك
المتحدث السابق باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
افادت وزاره الدفاعيه الروسيه ان القوات
الاستراتيجيه الصاروخيه بدات تدريبات
مقرره سلفا في منطقه
التابعه للمنطقه العسكريه الوسطى تشمل
انظمه صواريخ يارس النوويه البالسيه
العابره للقارات وقبله السواحل الكوريه
جرت تمرينات عسكريه مشتركه بين الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
كن مستعدا لكن لما لكل احتمال يرد
المتاهبون الكبار اذا لم تدخل للمناوره
العسكريه في تلك الخانه فهي في الغالب
حماله رسائل
ولعل منها منطلق مع صاروخ كروز فرد صوتي
من طراز موسكت مضاد للسفن اختبره الروس في
بحر اليابان لم تكت تمضي 24 ساعه على
الاختبار حتى بدات القوات الاستراتيجيه
الصاروخيه الروسيه تدريبات تشمل انظمه
صواريخ يارس النوويه البالستيه العابره
للقارات
وهنا تؤكد روسيا اقتناعها بضروره الحيوله
دون الاصطدام مع دول نوويه مع انها توقفت
عن اشعار الولايات المتحده بشان انشطتها
النوويه بما في ذلك اختبار الاسلحه
وما يختبره الامريكيون هذه الايام هو قدره
حلفاء لهم في منطقه المحيطين الهندي
والهادي على الصمود امام هجمات معاديه
محتمله هناك في اقصى جنوب شبه الجزيره
الكوريه المشحونه بالتوترات تجري الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه مناورات جويه
وبرمائيه انه الاستعداد كما يقول الجانبان
لاي هجوم قد يستهدف شبه الجزيره الكوريه
مخصص للدفاع عن شبه الجزيره الكوريه هو
مهم بالنسبه لنا وبالنسبه لاستقرار
المنطقه ككل
اكد كلامه سريعا بيان رسمي مشترك جدد
الالتزام بتقويه الروابط العسكريه
والامنيه بين واشنطن وسول من الشمال تراقب
تدريبات يقلقها انها تتوسع في تعزيز الرضع
وتشمل الاصول الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه على
مدى اسابيع تلاحقت الرسائل في الاتجاه
المعاكس
اطلاق صواريخ باليستيه واستعراض اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه بل ودعوه من قياده كوريا
الشماليه للاستعداد لشن هجمات النوويه في
اي لحظه
ارحب بضيفي حول هذا الملف من موسكو
الكسندر
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي وظيفه من
واشنطن الدكتور دينس وايلدر مدير شؤون
اسيا في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي سابقا
اهلا بكما وابدا بضيف من واشنطن
موسكو تؤكد ان هذه التمارين انما هي
مبرمجه ومجدوله
سابقا
ولكن توقيتها يقول غير ذلك كيف تجد هذه
التمارين
لا انا اسالك عن التمارين العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه النبويه الروسيه
من الصعب ان نعرف ما يحدث لان الروس كانوا
متكتمين بشكل كبير عن انشطتهم النكويه
وكما تعرفون من كافه
الاتفاقيات الموقعه معهم بهذا السدد اذا
ما نجد نفسنا امامه الان هو خطاب واحد من
قبيل من قبل موسكو وهناك بالتاكيد تشكي
كبير فيما تقوله وبالتالي كيف تفهم موسكو
هذه التمارين في اي سياق
عفوا واشنطن كيف واشنطن هذه الرسائل
اعتقد ان واشنطن
منزعجه من هذه المناورات ومن هذه التحركات
والمقاربات الجديده لبوتين بخصوص الاسلحه
النوويه وبدا بتحريك الاسلحه النوويه نحو
روسيا البيضاء بيلاروسيا وتحدثت حول
امكانيه استخدام اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه
والمنحى الذي يتخذه بوتين نحو القوه
النوويه هو مصدر انزعاج كبيره بالنسبه
ونحن نسعى
لاعادته الى ال الاتفاقيات الخاصه
بالاسلحه النوويه جدا ما يقوم به وهذه
المناورات موزعة بالنسبه للساسه في واشنطن
رغم انه موسكو تؤكد بان هذه التمارين
مجدوله ولكن توقيتها والمكان التجرى فيه
هذه التمارين
الا توصل بالضروره رساله
لواشنطن وحلفائها في هذه المنطقه تحديدا
في بحر اليابان
انك محق ان هذا مؤشر بعد سقوط المسيره
الامريكيه في البحر الاسود نقوم بالقيام
بمؤشرات الولايات المتحده المؤشرات
المختلفه التي تقول لامريكا ان لا تتدخل
في اراضي بعيده عن ارضها انها تحاول
محاصره روسيا من كل المناطق الناتو تحاول
نشر توسعها في مختلف المناطق بما فيها دول
المحيط الهادئ ونحن لدينا رده فعل
وتدريبات التي بدات منذ فتره طويله ونعلم
ان هذا لا يعجب الولايات المتحده نتحدث عن
البحر الصيني الجنوبي
الموجود في البحر الصيني
الجنوبي حيث تقوم الصين بالدفاع عن مياهها
ونحن ندعمهم في هذا هذه التدريبات هي في
ضوء
الصيني الروسي الذين يعتبوا يعتبرين
شريكين متساويين وسوف نستمر في العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه بيننا وبين الصين
دكتور وايلر لو افترضنا ان هذه التمارين
هي رساله موجهه
لواشنطن كيف على واشنطن تقراها
لو افترضنا ان هذه التمارين الروسيه هي
رساله مباشره موجهه لواشنطن كيف على
واشنطن ان تقرا هذه الرساله الروسيه
الروسيه ومخطئ تماما الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا تذهب الى تلك المناطق من اجل
مضاعفه قوتها نحن نذهب الى تلك المناطق
فقط لدعم حلفائنا
كوريا الجنوبيه على سبيل المثال بسبب
التهديدات التي تفرضها كوريا الشماليه
والصين وروسيا
الجنوبيه هي التي طلبت منا ان ناتي الى
المنطقه ولا
امريكا هي التي تذهب
بمفردها الى تلك المنطقه نفس الشيء ايضا
من قبل اليابان فهي التي تطلب منا ان نقوم
بمناورات معها ضيفكم تحدث حول التعاون
والتحالف ما بين روسيا والصين هذا تحديدا
ما يقلق محبي السلام في المنطقه
ضيفي من موسكو ايضا لو افترضنا ان هذه
الرساله رسائل مباشره من موسكو باتجاه
واشنطن كيف لهذه الرسائل الروسيه ان تحقق
الهدف منها باعتقادك
مره ثانيه لو افترضنا ان هذه الرسائل
موجهه من موسكو الى واشنطن ما هي الحسابات
الروسيه عندما قامت بهذه التمارين ان
رسالتها سوف تصل واشنطن كما تريدها موسكو
ان روسيا تريد ان تهتم الولايات المتحده
بمناطقها التابعه لها وهي
المناطق التابعه للولايات المتحده وقد
تكون بعض الدول المجاوره نحن لا نعلن عن
قلقنا عن ان اليابان حتى الان موضوع تحت
الاحتلال لان ليس لليابان اي حق ان تعترض
على اي تدريبات امريكيه على اراضيها
الخاصه لماذا نتحمل نحن هذا ان المشاكل
المفروضه من قبل الناتو الدول
المنضمه لها ان مؤتمر النيتو يبتعد على
مسافه قريبه لحدودنا ولم اسمع لاي مره ان
تكون
الكوريه الشماليه تهدد كوريا الجنوبيه
ولكننا نعلم ان السفن
الامريكيه التي تقترب من الحدود الكوريه
انتم تعلمون هذا جيدا كان منذ سنتين
شكرا لك من موسكو الكسندر الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي وكذلك الشكر لضيفي من واشنطن
مدير شؤون اسيا في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي سابقا
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قال
مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه ان المعركه من
اجل مدينه باكموت دمرت الجيش الاوكراني
رغم الحاقها ضررا بالغا بقوته وكان موقع
ريبار العسكري الروسي اعلن ان ميليشيا
فاجنر تواصل عملياتها الهجوميه للسيطره
على الشمال الغربي لبغمض واضاف ان معارك
عنيفه تدور حاليا داخل
في محيط منطقه بوغدانوفا
ومن جانبه قال اللواء الثالث الهجومي في
الجيش الاوكراني انه استهدف مجموعه من
قوات الجيش الروسي ومسلح فاغنر في محيط
باخموت ونشر اللواء الثالث الهجومي في
الجيش الاوكراني مشاهد لما قال انها عمليه
دقيقه استهدفت خلالها قواته جنودا روسا
ومقاتلين من مجموعه فاغنر في محيط مدينه
اوكرانيا التي تشهد قتالا مستمرا منذ شهور
اكد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني الاكسي ريزنكوب
ان بلاده تستعد لهجوم مضاد خلال شهرين
ابريل ومايو المقبلين مشيرا ان في حديث
لقناه محليه الى ان توقيت الاعمال
الهجوميه مرتبط بالظروف الجويه
سترون الدبابات في الهجوم المضاد وفق قرار
من هيئه الاركان العامه لدينا وهو هجوم تم
التخطيط له بالفعل في عده اتجاهات يعتمد
ذلك على اللحظه الملائمه ووفقا لقراراتهم
كما يعتمد على الظروف الجويه ففي الربيع
ارضنا تكون رطبه جدا وليس من السهل مرور
هذه المدرعات لذا اعتقد انكم سترون ذلك
خلال الشهرين القادمين واقصد في ذلك ابريل
ومايو
[موسيقى]
الجلسه الختاميه لورشه الاصلاح العسكري
والامنيه في السودان في غياب رئيس مجلس
السياده وقائد الجيش سعد الفتاح البرهان
ونائب رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان حميتي وممثلي الجيش
السوداني واشارت مصادر عسكريه سودانيه
للجزيره الى ان الجيش غير راضي عن الورقه
التي قدمها ممثل قواته الدعم السريع في
ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري لكونها لم
تتناول خطوات دمج الدعم السريع داخل الجيش
وقال المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه خالد
عمر يوسف ان عملا لجان المتخصصه من
المدنيين والعسكريين في ورشه الاصلاح
العسكري والامني ستتواصل لمناقشه الصيغات
العامه والتوصيات النهائيه لورشه الاصلاح
العسكري بغيه نشرها للراي العام
او اكد ممثل الاليه ثلاثيه المسهله للحوار
في السودان محمد بلعيش ان الاصلاح العسكري
مساله شائكه وانه لا يمكن حدوث انتقال
ديمقراطي في ظل تعدد الجيوش واوضح بالعيش
ان اصلاح القطاع العسكري في السودان يجب
ان يكون بالشراكه مع المجتمع الدولي على
حد تعبيره
انهاء ورشه العمل هذه اشاره ملموسه الى
هذا الالتزام بمعالجه موضوع صعب
وحساس في غالب الاحيان
ان مساله الادماج هي ايضا الموضوع شائك في
سياقه الانتقال
ولكنها مساله ضروريه
كما ذكرت الاليه مرارا وتكرارا لا يمكن
للسودان او للديمقراطيه
الازدهار في ظل وجود جيوش متعدده
هذا وكان محمد حمدان حباتي رئيس مجلس
السياده دعا في وقت سابق الى تاجيل دمج
قوات الدعم السريع في القوات المسلحه فقال
ان الاصلاح لابد ان يشمل مؤسسات الدوله
كافه داعيا لاخراج بند الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري من السجال السياسيه تماما واكد
حميتي ان قوات الدعم السريع ملتزمه
بالانحياز لخيار التحول الديمقراطي الذي
يضع السودان في مساره الصحيح
انادي بان يخرج هذا البلد من السجال
السياسي تماما فلا سبيل ضوضاء الهتافات
والشعارات في عمليه في عمليه في عمليه في
عمليه فنيه معقده وحساسه غالبا اجزائها
يجب ان يعالج خلف غرف محكمه محكمه الاغلاق
بلوغ النجاح في الاصلاح المنظومه الامنيه
والعسكريه مرتبط بالاهداب الساميه التي
نزع اليها والتي يجب ان تكون محل اجماع
وطني وهي ترفيع وتعزيز الامن القومي
السوداني ومؤسساتي بعيدا عن اي اجنده او
منافس او منافسه سياسيه
معنى من الخرطوم الكاتب الصحفي حافظ كبير
وايضا بعد من الخرطوم اللواء بابكر يوسف
المدير السابق للاعلام العسكري اهلا بكم
وابدا بك معك سيد حافظ عن محاوله فهم
لماذا هذا الغياب لهذه الورشه من قبل قوه
الدعم السريع
تحيه طيبه
ولمشاهديكم الكرام انا اعتقد ان الغياب
ليس من قبل قوات الدعم السريع وانما
الغياب من قبل الجيش والخبر يتحدث عن
انسحاب ممثلين الجيش بينما ظل ممثلي الدعم
السريع موجودون في القاعه حتى تلاوه
البيان الختامي هناك لم يحضر الجلسه هذا
ليس خبر
لم يحضر باعتبار ان هناك اتفاق ان يحضر
الجميع الورشه ختام الورشه وان يحضروا
ايضا ختار الورشه التي بداوها مع بعض
وبالتالي حضور احدهم قد قد يمثل اشاره
سالبه وبالتالي انسحب ممثل الجيش عن عن
الختام وبالتالي ليس هناك موقفا واضحا لكن
بصوره عامه كل النقاشات
التوصيات التي اتفق عليها الاطراف كل
الاطراف كان ممثل للجيش موجود فيها الا
انه ما انسحبوا مؤخرا بعد تحديد جلسه
صياغه التوصيات بعد ان يرى البعض ان
التوصيات لم تاتي يعني وفقا لما يريدونه
وبالتالي انسحبوا عن الجلسه الختاميه ولم
يحضروا تلاوه البيان الختامي هناك طبعا
حديث كثير جدا ان النقاشات كانت تدور بشكل
قاسي وبشكل صريح وشفاف حول الاشكال الكبير
في الجيش والاشكال الكبير في المواساه
الامنيه برمتها وبالتالي قدم ورقه للاصلاح
وكذلك قدمت دعم السريع ورقي للاصلاح الورق
التي قدمها لدعم السريع ورقه شامله تتحدث
عن الاصلاح بصوره عامه اما البعض في قياده
الجيش ينظر الى الامر باعتباره دمج ومساله
الدمج هي مساله فرعيه
الى التاجيل في النقاش لهذه المساله وان
يشمل الموضوع بقيه وانا اسال ضيفي ايضا من
الخرطوم اللواء ابو بكر يوسف عن عدم حضور
السيد البرهان وممثلي المؤسسه العسكريه
لهذه الورشه ما الذي يعنيه ذلك
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك ومشاهدي
قناه الجزيره
انا ارى انه في هذا الامر ليس هنالك يعني
شيء يعني انسحاب جيش او عدم انسحابه طالما
ان المناقشات تدور في دمج القوات واصلاح
المؤسسه العسكريه لكن في تقدير الشخصي ان
الاصلاح المؤسسه العسكريه ليس بالسرعه
التي نراها وورشه لا تمثل يعني هي حل
وحلول للقوات المسلحه او لجيش وطني موحد
حقيقه كما تعلم ان هنالك تعاقدات ومعقدات
كبيره جدا اعداد كبيره من الجيوش للحركات
المسلحه وقيره تحتاج للدمج في القوات
المسلحه والدمج في القوات المسلحه
والاستيعاب يتم عبر اللوائح وقوانين
والقوات المسلحه يعني ليست جديده في هذا
الامر سبق لها تجربه في حركه انانيه 2
وبعض الحركات ولكن
لماذا لم يحضر السيد الب رهان او ممثلي عن
المجلس العسكري
ويناقش ويرفض ما جاء في هذه الورشه بدلا
من المقاطعه وعدم الحضور
[موسيقى]
عندما يدعو السيد حميتي الى تاجيل هذا
الموضوع فيما قد يقراه البعض انه رفض بشكل
او باخر لمساله الادماج هل هناك منظور
زمني للقيام بهذه الخطوه
يعني هو هناك يعني تصور للدعم السريع
وكذلك تصور للقوه المدنيه باعتبار ان
المؤسسات جميعها بها خلل كبير واذا ما
دمجت الجيوش في الجيش بهذه الوضعيه
الحاليه ربما يتم استخدام هذه الجيوش
لوجهه غير التحول لمدني الديمقراطي
وبالتالي هناك يعني اشتراطات
باصلاح المنظومه كلها وليس التركيز على
منظومه بعينها ينبغي اصلاح المؤسسات كله
حتى يعني تستوعب المرحله الجديده حتى تكون
خاضعه للمسائله وللشفافيه وتكون كذلك
خاضعه
ايضا واعذرني على المقاطعه في هذه الحاله
بقيه الاطراف تقول لماذا لا نبدا بالمؤسسه
العسكريه والمؤسسات شبه العسكريه ومن
خلالها ننتقل الى بقيه المؤسسات واصبحنا
من يسبق البيضه ام الدجاجه
هناك ورقه متفق عليها بين اطراف الاتفاق
الاطاري سميت بالاسس اسس اصلاح الامن
العسكري حددت مراحل المرحله الاولى مرحله
دمج هيئه الاركان هناك مراحل كثيره جدا
الخطه وكذلك يعني نحن الان نتحدث عن وضع
في السودان خارج من حرب وقتال وكذلك قوات
مختلفه لا بد من وضع خطه شامله لعمليه
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري ولابد كذلك من
وضع تصورات
وبدائل لهؤلاء الجمرات الذين ظلوا طوال
الفتره السابقه يعملون في طوال فتره الحرب
لديهم مصالح اقتصاديه واجتماعي وكذلك يعني
هذا الامر معقد وبالتالي يعني امر دمج او
امر الحديث فقط عن الدم هو مختزل الاختزال
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري شكرا لا يصلحها
ولا بالتالي ربما ينظر البعض اليه
باعتباره فقط لتغيير بعض القوى من المشهد
السياسي وكذلك
شكرا جزيلا لك وكذلك ضيفي من الخرطوم
اللواء بكر يوسف المدير السابق للاعلام
العسكري
[موسيقى]
في مزيد من اخبار عبر العالم قالت وكاله
الانباء الامارات ان رئيس الدوله بصفته
حاكما لاماره ابوظبي اصدر قرارا بتعيين
الشيخ خالد بن محمد بن زايد وليا للعهد في
اماره ابوظبي واضافت الوكاله ان رئيس
الدوله بصفته حاكما لاماره ابو ظبي عين
الشيخ هزاع بن زايد والشيخ طحنون بن زايد
ابين لحاكم اماره ابوظبي كما اصدر رئيس
الدوله بموافقه المجلس الاعلى للاتحاد
قرارا بتعيين الشيخ منصور بن زايد نائبا
لرئيس الدوله الى جانب الشيخ محمد بن راشد
ال مكتوم
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان لهجه
واشنطن تجاه تايوان وزيارات مسؤوليه
للولايات المتحده لم يتغير كما هو حال
سياسه الصين الواحده وقد بدات رئيسه
تايوان
رحله الى امريكا اللاتينيه تتوقف خلالها
في الولايات المتحده في طريق ذهابها
وتلتقي مشرعين امريكيين وحذرت الصين التي
تعتبر تايوان جزءا من اراضيها من هذا
التوقف في الاراضي الامريكيه وقالت ان هذا
الامر يعد استفزازا لبيجيم وقال المكتب
الحكومي الصيني لشؤون تايوان ان الامر
يلحق الضرر بسياده الصين ووحده اراضيها
ويقوض السلام والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان
كما حذر من ان الصين ستتخذ اجراءات للرد
بشكل حازم وحثت واشنطن على عدم اجراء اي
اتصال رسمي برئيسه تايوان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين اليوم ان
العقوبات الدوليه التي فرضت في اعقاب حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا قد تكون لها تداعيات
سلبيه وذلك بعد اشهر من تاكيده ان موسكو
تتكيف مع الواقع الاقتصادي الجديد ويعتبر
قطاع التكنولوجيا في روسيا احد اهم
القطاعات المتضرره من العقوبات الغربيه
بعد الصدمه الاوليه تحاول هذه الشركه
المختصه في قطاع الاتصالات تعويض غياب
مهندسي البرمجيات الذين غادروا البلاد
والحصول على قطع الغيار
المحظور تصديرها الى روسيا فضلا عن تغطيه
الفراغ الذي حصل في القطاع بعد ان انسحبت
عشرات الشركات من السوق مهمه عصيه لكنها
ليست مستحيله وفق تعبيرهم
استطعنا الحصول على قطع غيار عبر قنوات
بديله ولا نزال نعاني نقصا في عدد
التقنيين
كل هذا يزيد حجم الضغط علينا خاصه ان عددا
كبيرا من الشركات غادرت البلد
من بين الذين غادروا البلاد اكثر من 100
الف متخصص في تكنولوجيا المعلومات لجاوا
الى دول غربيه نزيف تصبو روسيا الى ايقافه
عبر حزمه من الاجراءات
عن فرض قيود على موظفي البرمجه الذين
يعملون عن بعد لصالح شركات روسيه لان اي
قيود ستدفع بهم للعمل في شركات اجنبيه
وعدم العوده الى البلاد
امام الحواجز الاوروبيه عثرت بعض الشركات
الناشئه على اسواق بديله في الشرق الاوسط
واسيا ولتفادي فقدان طاقمها سارعت الى
اتخاذ اجراءات عاجله
خاصه للعاملين في مجال البرمجه لتفادي
التعبئه في الجيش وهو محل دون مغادره
موظفين وممكن شركتنا من تفادي نقص الكوادر
يعترف المسؤولون الروس بقسوه العقوبات
التي استهدفت قطاعهم التكنولوجي لكنهم
يرون ايضا ان تلك العقوبات دفعتهم
للاعتماد على النفس واستثمار مواردهم على
نحو غير مسبوق للوصول الى استقلال
تكنولوجي يؤمن مصالح المواطنين والشركات
ايمن الزبير الجزيره موسكو
[موسيقى]
ضمن مساعيها للحد من تاثير العقوبات
الغربيه على اقتصادها وقعت روسيا اتفاقا
جديدا مع الهند لزياده امدادها بالنفط
الخام الاتفاق وقعته في نيودلهي شركه
النفط الهنديه المحدوده مع شركه النفط
الروسيه العملاقه روزنفت لكن دون الكشف عن
تفاصيل هذا العقد وبحسب وكاله
اصبحت الهند سوقا رئيسيه للنفط الروسي
الرخيص في ظل العقوبات الغربيه المفروضه
على موسكو ردا على غزوها لاوكرانيا وقدرت
وكاله الطاقه الدوليه متوسطه صادرات النفط
الروسي الى الهند في فبراير الماضي بنحو
مليون و700 الف برميل يوميا وذلك على حساب
دول النفطيه اخرى كالعراق والسعوديه وامس
اعلنت روسيا ان صادراتها النفطيه الى
الهند ازدادت في العام الماضي 22 مره عما
كانت عليه قبل حرب اوكرانيا المفارقه فان
الخامه الروسي الرخيص تكرره المصافي
الهنديه ثم تعيد نيودلهي طبعا تصديره الى
اوروبا والولايات المتحده على شكل مشتقات
من وقود وكذلك من زيوت الاتفاق الهندي
الروسي يرفع حجم شراكه الاقتصاديه بين
البلدين الى مستويات غير مسبوقه ورغم
انتقادات الغرب ترفض نيودله وقفه التعاون
مع موسكو لانه يتعارض مع مصلحته الوطنيه
وفق قولها وبفعل الاسعار التفضيليه اصبحت
روسيا اكبر مورد نفط للهند بنسبه نحو 27%
من اصل خمسه ملايين برميل نفط تستوردها
نيودلهي يوميا طبعا هذه دفعت تلك الزيادات
البلدين الى تسويه بعض المشتريات النفطيه
بعملات غير الدولار الامريكي الذي يعتبر
عمله التداول الرئيسيه عالميا ببحث هذا
الخط الا قتصادي وان كان فيه ايضا ابعاد
اخرى نستقبل ضيفنا من اوسلو الدكتور
جليمديسن وهو استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
بجامعه
اهلا بك دكتور جلين كيف تجد هذا الخط بين
موسكو ونيودلهي في بعده الاقتصادي وكذلك
الابعاد الاخرى
هذا الخط ما بين الهند وروسيا مهم جدا
لان روسيا في المرحله الراهنه تحاول ان
تنوع اقتصادها خاصا باتجاه الشرق وتحاول
ان تقلل منه اعتمادها على الغرب الصين
ايضا ربما اهم شريك الان بالنسبه لروسيا
لكن روسيا لا تريد ان تكون معتمده بشكل
كبير على الصين وهدفها هو ان تنوع من
شراكاتها الاقتصاديه الشراكه مع الهند
مهمه الان في هذه المرحله ونحن نرى تقدما
كبيرا قبل عام روسيا والهند لم يكن لديهما
كثير من التبادل التجاري وانطلاقا من
نوفمبر راينا روسيا تحولت الى اكبر مصدر
للنفط للهند بالتالي هذا الخط لديه هي
بالتاكيد تبعات ايجابيه للبلدي هل سيؤثر
ذلك على العقوبات المفروضه على روسيا خاصه
جزء من الاتفاق الهندي الروسي ان جزء من
المشتقات النفطيه سيتم التعامل بغير
الدولار
نعم بكل تاكيد هذا صحيح لا يمكنك ان تفرض
عقوبات شامله على بلدان كبيره
كاروسيا وتعقب الاخرى
الهند نحن نعلم ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فرضت عقوبات على روسيا لكن الان
البلدان اي روسيا والهند
سيتاجران ويتعاملان بعمله اخرى بكل بساطه
وهم
يعملان وهما يعملان على التطوير انظمه
تامين بديله ويعملون بناء اساطيل
لنقلات النفط اساطير جديده روسيا والهند
يتفقان على ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لم يعد ذلك الطرف او الشريك الموثوق به
بايجاز دكتور جلين كيف ترى تاثير هذا
الاتفاق على قطاع النفط في روسيا
نعم
من
الصناعات النفطيه ينبغي ان يعاد تاهلها في
البلد وهناك كما قلت تركيز على الشرق اكثر
منه على الخربه الان
الهند تقوم بمعالجه النبضه واعاده بيعه
الوقت ضيفي من اوسلو الدكتور كلين نادي
العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه
شكرا جزيلا لك